[inaudible].
I'm on a one day break from touring with Jordan Peterson and joining me in
studio today is a free speech lawyer and the director of the Individual Rights
Defense Program at the foundation for Individual Rights in education,
Aka fire are in code.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
That was a wordy intro.
A lot of freedom stuff in there and that's all the stuff that I like.
So I'm looking forward to this same.
So you guys,
fire as an organization is one of the few bastions of sanity these days.
Like when I see what you guys are tweeting about and consistently defending the
principles of free speech and free expression and open inquiry,
I'm always like,
ah,
there are some good guys left.
So first,
uh,
can you just tell me a little bit about the organization,
why you guys got started,
how you personally got involved?
Well,
we got started in 1999,
uh,
with a professor at Penn and a civil liberties lawyer in Philadelphia who were,
you know,
they both decided that there were,
uh,
there was a problem,
there was an epidemic at our colleges and universities of the core individual
rights that,
that make up,
you know,
our,
our constitution,
if you will.
Um,
as individuals,
as people,
as citizens of the United States,
uh,
broke being respected on campuses across the,
the country back in 99 they nine.
Yeah.
That's interesting because a lot of people say this is just the totally recent
phenomenon.
Well,
I think is,
you know,
a lot of it there,
the political correctness movement of the eighties and nineties,
a little bit,
you know,
that might've had something to do with it,
but this has been a problem since the free speech movement back at Berkeley.
I,
you know,
long before even the eighties or nineties,
censorship is an age old problem,
predates the United States of America.
Really?
Uh,
and as Alan and Harvey,
you know,
went about creating fire and they decided to locate it and like located in
Philadelphia,
which is the birthplace of our nation,
they really got an outpouring of people saying,
Hey,
this happened to me too.
Uh,
and they said,
well,
this is,
you know,
this is a problem.
This is an epidemic.
We need to fix it.
And then fire was born,
um,
or,
or lit,
if you will.
And uh,
over the years getting close to 20 now,
crazy enough that has actually just gone up every year more and more people
reach out to fire for help.
Um,
you know,
when I got to fire for the second time,
I actually was a legal fellow at fire after I graduated from law school,
before I started in private practice.
Uh,
but when I came back in 2013 getting several hundred case submissions a year,
um,
and now we are getting damn near close to a thousand a year.
Wow.
Credible.
And that's just the stuff that we hear about.
Can only imagine how much other stuff is going on around the country.
For people who don't know that we're out there to them.
Uh,
or you know,
people who perhaps go about it themselves.
It's,
it's crazy to think about how much is going on.
Yeah.
So I want to talk about some of those cases and some of the specific work that
you're doing,
but foundation for individual rights in education.
I am a believer right now partly because of Kanye West and because of a lot of
people online right now that the individual is making a comeback,
that the idea of the individual versus the collective is actually making a
comeback.
Do you have any idea when they came up with the name for fire,
why it was so important to put the individual front and center?
I think it's,
you know,
and I'm speaking,
out of some level of ignorance because I haven't actually discussed this with
either of them personally,
but you know,
if I had to guess,
it's because the individual qualities,
the freedom of conscious,
the freedom of speech for things that allow us to participate in society.
We don't get to the collective unless we have the individuals.
One is necessary to have the other because what is a collective other than a
group of individuals and consensus is a bunch of individual opinions that
throughout the process of winnowing and debating different good ideas and bad
ideas,
we reach a common understanding.
We reach a,
uh,
you know,
in norm for society.
And that's how,
that's why free speech particularly is so important just because that's how we
get to the optimal resolution,
the optimal conclusions.
That's how we reach these communal positions is only through our own personal
expressions of what we believe,
which exposes us to criticism or agreement or just flat out discussion with
other people.
So how do you think the ideas of the collective took root so much a college
campus then?
Well,
I think there's the given take in society at large that we really go through
every once in a while in terms of thinking about things as individualistic and
then worrying about broader concerns of the community.
And it's not altogether a bad thing.
And I think the college campus,
and it's always been this way,
it's a microcosm of what we're experiencing in the broader society.
And I think that's another reason why it's so important to protect individual
rights on college campuses,
uh,
because where they fall on college campuses,
there are almost certainly short to fall in society writ large.
Yeah.
So that actually we discussed this briefly right before the camera's turned on.
That's my concern about this.
When people say,
Oh,
you know,
there isn't a free speech issue on college campuses and even though I keep going
to college campuses,
and it's very clear to me that there is a free speech problem there,
that it's not what's going to happen.
It's not just the screaming kids right now.
It's not that it's that these are the people that are going to be in leader ship
positions five,
10 15 years in the future and further than that obviously.
And if those ideas take root because they were able to silence us once they are
the lawmakers,
once they're in charge of public policy,
they're not going to be too kind to the people who they were silencing way back
when.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
that's really one of the key problems.
And it's not even just if they get elected to power,
even if they aren't elected,
uh,
and they don't rise to power and they can impose these views on other people.
These are future citizens,
even if they're not necessarily future leaders.
And then discourse of the nation,
if that is the,
the prevalent feeling in society is going to suffer tremendously as a result if
even if they're not in Congress or in the state legislatures,
if 50% of the country's population thinks that we shouldn't be talking about
certain things,
we're not going to talk about these things and it's going to be a societal
societaly imposed,
if nothing else.
And I think that's incredibly damaging to just about every aspect of our life is
as a country.
Yeah.
It's so interesting to me because I know you,
you read about this,
but I was at the University of New Hampshire a couple of weeks ago and you know,
first we were supposed to give a speech on campus.
Then about two hours before they announced that they couldn't secure the room,
that they felt there were too many threats.
So there were about 200 or 250 people is supposed to be in the room.
They moved us to the hockey rink,
which seats 7,500 people.
So I stood in front of a little,
you know,
backdrop and I talked to about 200 people.
It was about 150 people that were there to listen and be respectful and all that
stuff.
And then they were about probably about 50 protesters roughly.
Those are the rough numbers.
Um,
but the desire just to shout down,
to use noise makers to scream to chant like robots,
they love robotic chance,
all of these things.
And I kept saying to them,
guys,
do you have any direct questions?
Is there something that I've said that you disagree with or is there something
you directly like to ask me and time and time again,
the answer was no and I don't know how you break them out of that other than
keep having these conversations and hope that the refugees make it to us and
that's a common problem.
I think it really comes down to ideological purity that people are after the
idea that if I disagree with you on something,
whether it's small or even fundamental,
if I disagree,
I disagree with you on that one thing.
That means nothing that you have to say could possibly be a value to me and that
is completely false.
You couldn't be farther from the truth.
We can learn so much from the people we disagree with the most.
Even if I disagreed with you on absolutely everything,
it would still be incredibly valuable for me to talk to you if only because that
helps me sharpen and really understand why I believe what I believe in and
people really discount the importance of understanding why you believe
something.
Yeah.
So the argument that I've been making for a while is that,
and I do think right now,
at least in 2018 and this is more of a problem on the left,
that they've owned the ideas and the narrative and the college campus discussion
and academia and media and all that.
They've owned that for so long that the reason these kids end up be,
are these students ended up being so hysterical is because they never hear a
counter ideas.
So then you get a pretty moderate guy who's arguing about liberty and freedom
for everybody and live and let live.
And that actually offends them because they never hear anything outside of what
they're being taught.
That goes to the academic part,
I think mostly.
Well,
I think we're doing a really crappy job of educating students before they get to
college about why free speech and our other rights are important.
Civics education is clearly in the toilet right now.
Uh,
and it's bizarre to me.
I grew up in Skokie,
Illinois,
one of the sites,
one of the most famous free speech cases,
you know,
in recent history.
Yeah.
Can you lay it out for those that don't know this,
the story in the 70s,
the American,
the American Socialist Party,
that Nationalist Party,
the Illinois Nazis,
if you'd ask the blues brothers wanted to march through Skokie,
Illinois,
which outside of New York had the largest concentration of Holocaust survivors
in the United States.
Uh,
and Skokie tried to stop them.
And uh,
they sued with the aid of the American Civil Liberties Union of Illinois.
And it went to,
well,
both the Supreme Court of Illinois on the Supreme Court in the United States.
And the Nazis had the right to March and the courts held so,
and there were threats of violence and disruption and all,
you know,
people out crying as to how this could be allowed.
But ultimately the Nazis had the first amendment right to march through Skokie.
And I grew up learning about that case from a very young age.
I can't tell you how many times I saw the movie they made about it.
And it really,
it got me thinking at a young age about why this is important,
how I think about it.
And I can't tell you that as a young child,
I completely agree that the Nazi should have a right to march.
When I was that young,
I part of me didn't grasp the overarching fundamental importance of free speech,
but I was thinking about it at least and I got there and I get the feeling that
sometimes we're not doing enough to make our students think about why it's
important.
It's such an important case and I'm glad you mentioned it because it goes really
to the heart of this that the people that lived in Skokie,
as you said,
the second largest amount of Holocaust survivors in the country,
these people literally survived a genocide.
Probably virtually all of them lost.
Some of them probably lost all of their family members and friends and all of
that,
and yet I would sit here as someone that lost Holocaust survivors on both sides
of my family and tell you it was the right decision.
You can't let the Nazis are the white supremacist or whatever they are.
You can't let them start ransacking property.
You can't let them start killing people or harming people,
but letting,
letting them march,
that's the exchange of free speech and it's kind of Shitty,
but you got to defend when it's hard to defend,
but you have to find it when it's hard to,
to defend because otherwise there's not going to be around to defend with.
It's easy to defend.
Uh,
you know,
once you start creating exceptions and encroaching,
uh,
there's no end to it.
And you know,
we've kind of seen even in other countries,
uh,
that once the encroachments start,
it's always,
well,
we make that exception and just this one other small exception.
And then there's inevitably and another one and another one and all for perhaps
even,
you know,
good reasons in terms of,
ideals and the goals are,
are laudable.
Perhaps fight every show.
The road to hell is paved with good intentions.
Getting tired.
It's you and me both.
Yeah.
But you know,
it's really practically speaking,
it's inevitable.
Yeah.
How much of this is just a confusion as to what the First Amendment is?
That's also what I've started to realize because when I've gone on college
campuses and the protesters are there and I always say it,
I welcome peaceful protests.
I completely welcome,
I welcome the exchange of ideas,
the questions,
all of that.
But when,
when they're screaming about certain things,
I think there's just a disconnect as to what I think too.
Legal things.
I think what the First Amendment is and what hate speech is is or isn't a so can
you talk about that a little bit?
Yeah.
I,
if I had to have to hear one more person,
whether it be student,
uh,
Internet commenter,
even journalists are faculty members sometimes say hate speech is not free
speech.
I'm going to lose it.
Okay.
So let's do,
let's do that one first.
Cause I,
I really,
I mean this'll be maybe what we promote for this episode,
but I really want people to understand this.
Why is hate speech free speech?
Well on a legal level,
hate speech is free speech because,
uh,
the first amendment and the courts have said nothing about free or hate speech
being unprotected by the first amendment.
Speech is protected by the First Amendment unless it falls under one of the very
few existing categories of unprotected speech.
Yeah.
What are,
what are those categories?
There's incitement to imminent lawless action on these all have very high bars,
right?
True threats and intimidation.
Uh,
you can be sued for libel or slander.
Defamation is,
they're known that some states I think actually still have criminal statutes on
the book books,
but they're rarely enforced fraud obscenity,
which people often confuse with mere profanity or lewdness,
but they are not the same thing by any stretch of the imagination.
What's the difference on those two?
Well,
profanity and lewdness are generally protected by the first amendment.
Obscenity is a very high bar.
It's speech that has to be our expression,
I should say more broadly than just speech.
Uh,
that has to appeal to the [inaudible] interest,
which is an inordinate fascination with sex,
describe or depict sex in a patently offensive way.
And have no social,
political,
literary or artistic value whatsoever and to get down in the,
in the mud.
Uh,
have you ever heard of crushed videos?
I feel like I have,
but I'm honestly not sure when that is.
They are videos of women wearing stilettos crushing small animals like hamsters
and journals to death and people apparently get off on that.
Yeah.
I don't pretend to understand it.
Even that is not wholly unprotected by the obscenity exception to the first
amendment.
That that's particularly interesting case I suppose because the idea of it
talking about it seems like a,
I would have no problem with that,
but the action itself,
probably there's some legal reasons,
right?
Like killing it,
killing animals.
There's some law I guess of Tri State Law,
right.
But if you have this,
ah,
pornography can call it that.
I just,
I have a hard time getting it.
Yeah.
Um,
if you have it in you to possess it,
you can't be prosecuted for possessing that obscene material.
It's an interesting distinction that the act is the crime or the act is what is
illegal,
not the depiction depiction or the disseminating of the information or that sort
of thing.
Right.
Uh,
child pornography obviously not protected by the First Amendment,
uh,
you know,
but
there's,
well,
there's the one additional wrinkle of the fighting words doctrine,
although there's considerable doubt that it remains a viable,
uh,
exception to the first amendment,
but it really gets brought up a lot in the hate speech debate.
Um,
to the extent it still exists,
it's limited to face to face interactions where say I say something to you that
is so insanely abusive that you are likely to punch me in the face without
thinking twice about it instead of taking a deep breath and either ignoring me
or coming back at me and there's reasons why it's fallen into disuse.
And it's worth wild to note that the Supreme Court has upheld a fighting words,
convictions since the case in the forties when it created the fighting words,
et Cetera.
It's interesting just how far it's fallen into disuse.
Uh,
it incentivizes punching people in the face.
Right.
It creates an easy way to sensor the people that you disagree with.
And it would,
I assume be some level of a subjective piece of information as to what you think
is offensive at the highest order is different perhaps than what I think or
exactly what some of these other people,
it creates terrible incentives and it would basically lead to an
institutionalized heckler's veto.
Uh,
so it's really not tenable.
Yeah.
So on the,
on the hate speech front,
which it's clear what the Supreme Court has said about hate speech,
you're allowed to do it with,
with these exceptions that you've just laid out,
you're allowed to see me in things.
What I,
what I'm realizing on college campuses is they really don't like that.
The people,
the set of people that we're talking about,
they really don't like that.
So like they think if you like,
it's just the fact you are allowed to say bad things.
You can say,
I hate all the Jews.
You can say I hate all the people or all the gays or whatever.
You can say it.
You can't cause direct call to violence.
But what I think they think is that if you keep saying those things,
I hate these people that it's going to incite violence.
Now my counter argument would be no,
you have to use free speech to counter those bad ideas.
That's the whole purpose of free speech.
But do you see that,
that that seems to be the slope that they consistently are on that if we allow
you to say,
I hate these people,
which is bigoted and prejudice and all those things,
but it's afforded to us by the bill of rights,
they think that that's going to get you to violence.
How do you combat that notion if you agree with the premise?
Well that is something that we tend to hear a lot in the first amendment world
to have.
And you know,
first of all,
generally speaking in this country,
we punish the people who do the bad acts.
If I watch your show and I get some Kooky idea and go off and you know,
commit some crime,
we're not going to throw you in jail because I'm an idiot and took a terrible
idea that you didn't even intend me to take right now.
It might be,
it might be different though if I was up here saying you should violently attack
these people,
et cetera.
It's right.
Exactly.
That's why the incitement standard is so high.
Yes.
Has to be likely to insight and intended to incite immediate criminal action.
So if I tell you,
hey,
you know,
it'd be fun to burn down a building,
but you're not likely to do it,
you're going to take it as a joke.
I probably haven't committed any kind of,
uh,
you know,
unlawful expression.
If I know you're a pyromaniac and I say,
Hey Dave,
let's go burn down a building.
Right?
I might find myself in a very different situation,
sort of left that phase at about eight years old.
But,
um,
but you know,
I think that
if you take a look,
one of my colleagues actually wrote a piece for Colette.
Uh,
not so long ago about the Rwandan genocide and looking over the claims that the
radio broadcasts actually,
you know,
caused more violence.
And what it turns out is that the radio broadcasts first of all,
only incited people who were already predisposed and who already felt that way.
And it made it marginally easier for them to find people and you know,
be taught how to do certain things,
but it was relatively ineffective as it turns out in convincing people who
weren't already in a murderous rage to go out and commit violence.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
I think that the fear that allowing these views to be aired is going to
indisputably cause actual violence is somewhat overblown.
Now there's a second part to it,
which is that people expressing these views might lead to more people adopting
those views and having prejudice views.
Is that possible?
Absolutely.
Right.
So that's the part I was referenced,
but kind of the point is that we put those use out there so we can fight them.
If we don't have them in public and we can't fight them,
they're still going to spread nothing.
No idea.
Ever went away because we said,
you can't say that.
It just doesn't work like that.
How does the heckler's veto fit into all of this?
Because one of the things that I again see on college campuses is when hecklers
starts screaming at you and then you say,
just a second,
you know,
if I'll get to your question or calm down or whatever you might say,
um,
they'll say,
well,
I have a right to free speech too.
They try to flip it on you to make you look like a hypocrite.
That actually kind of kind of gets me,
but I will give them a little bit of credit.
I think you say a university event and somebody comes in and they chant for 30
seconds or they stand up and turn their backs and that's the extent of it.
I think that we should protect that technically.
Are they causing a disruption?
Yes,
but it's minimal and it's actually maximized the amount of free speech.
There has to be some room for very minimal disruption,
but when it gets to the point where they are substantially interfering with the
speakers ability to get their message across or the audience's ability to hear
them through repeated shouting or noise makers or you know,
standing in the front and blocking everyone's views and things like that,
obviously that's a problem.
And last year we just saw a rash of,
of the heckler's vetoes going on and it kind of all started with Berkeley and
Milo Yiannopoulos when they protestors were successful in shutting down the
event through of what had bef before that been unfathomable on a college campus
for an invited speaker.
We've seen invited speaker controversies since fire was founded.
Basically never ever am I aware of any incident that came close to something
like that.
It was just madness.
Yeah,
and they got away with it.
So few arrests were made,
and I can't help but wonder if the students out at Middlebury College where
Charles Murray was speaking,
sees done that and looked at the Berkeley students and said,
well,
they were successful in stopping that event with speech that we also did tested
and they got away with it.
So let's try that.
It's a viable tactic.
This might be a solution for keeping this speech.
We disagree with off campus and ideas like that,
that the tactics that students are able to successfully utilize,
they will.
Behavior that is rewarded essentially is going to be repeated.
Yeah.
And I see that all over the place right now.
So for example,
just a couple months after Milo went to Berkeley in that happen,
uh,
Ben Shapiro's spoke there and it was largely nonviolent,
but it costs the $600,000 to make that happen.
I mean,
I think an ATM was broken in a couple of windows and that's it.
But that's part of the tactic is if we can keep ramping this up,
we'll keep pushing the security costs.
And as I said,
they had to move my event to a freaking hockey theater that uh,
you know,
hockey arena that couldn't have been cheap and,
and several other than these I saw,
I'm sure you're familiar with the case of Lindsay Shepherd up at Wilfrid Laurier
in Canada and she just had to crowd fund I think around six grand to get
security for one of her events.
So that almost seems like the new tactic.
It's almost like we don't have to,
we can scare them with some threats of violence and some other stuff and then
will cause the security costs to be so high that you guys will just give up.
Well,
and that's another problem we've been fighting since even before all of this
came to a head is uh,
colleges and universities trying to charge student groups security fees for the
speakers based on the anticipated protest or controversy.
And that's plainly unconstitutional.
It has been for a long time since the supreme court said that a listener's
reaction is not a content neutral basis for regulation.
You cannot charge more for controversial speakers because they might drop
protest.
That place is a price tag on expression and prices.
Like you said,
it'll price the controversial expression out of the marketplace.
They're not going to be able to afford it.
What student group has $17,000 to spend on security?
None of them.
And you know what it comes down to is administrators at the university itself
has to be the guarantor of last resort when it comes to speakers and ability to
speak.
And this is the business they are in.
And sometimes it's unpleasant and sometimes it costs a whole lot of money.
But if you're not going to have a campus where we can discuss things and we can
debate things,
even if it gets loud and boisterous and rockets and contentious,
which is everything free speech should be,
if your campus isn't going to be a place where that occurs,
then what are you,
what are you doing?
So I do want to make a point of saying that some of the campuses are getting it
right and I'm sure you know,
some of the campuses that are doing a little better than some of the others.
Uh,
but for example,
uh,
at the beginning of September,
2017,
I spoke at Claremont Mckenna at there,
they're doing a big free speech push because of what happened the semester
before with Heather McDonald and all hell broke loose and on the campus.
And I was completely welcome there and they,
even some of the students who disagreed with me,
I mean they asked healthy questions and all of that good stuff.
So it's where I always think it's worth mentioning that some schools are doing
their best to manage some of this stuff.
Absolutely.
And on two levels,
I think,
you know,
first of all,
fire rates,
policies at schools,
we raised over 400 different colleges and universities on our red light,
yellow light,
green light level,
a red light being,
you have policies that are clearly in substantially unconstitutional yellow
being you have policies that are susceptible to being applied in bad ways and
greenlight schools where none of their policies poses a serious threat to free
speech.
In the past couple of years,
the number of greenlight schools that we have has nearly doubled,
which is tremendous.
Now still close to 60% of schools have a yellow light.
So there's work to be done.
But you combine that with the 38 schools that have now put out statements
expressively committing themselves to free speech.
Uh,
something that,
you know,
the University of Chicago kicked off a while back.
There's reasons to be hopeful and we work regularly with administrators who are
happy to have us,
you know,
consult on their policies and say,
here are the changes we would make a and we are,
we have amicable relationships with so many administrators,
which is really gratifying.
But on the student side also,
part of it is overblown.
I think by media.
There are a lot of students out there who do get it and people of all ideologies
and all political,
uh,
you know,
sides.
There are a lot of students out there who get it.
I speak to them on a daily basis and I,
there is a lot of reason to have hope.
This is not a lost cause.
No,
I agree.
I think it's important talking about it because even again at that University of
New Hampshire,
I 75% of the crowd at least was there respectfully decently to hear ideas and,
and do that what I felt was important after and why I still want to talk about
it and have you here and all that is because I want people to be armed with the
right arguments so that when these,
this set of people,
even if it's just a smaller set that's just really loud,
who has a disproportionate amount of influence,
I want people to understand there are tactics you can use to,
to fight it.
So I'm curious on that list of 38 schools that's kind of doing it right right
now when they've instituted some of these policies.
And I remember when University of Chicago did it about a year ago,
um,
is there evidence that things actually get better?
Cause I,
I'm going to guess that when you give some rules,
some of these students,
they don't want to be kicked out of school and they might actually behave
better.
Well,
so I think you know this,
there's a lot of conversation right now about some legislation even that's going
on about disrupting speeches,
mandatory punishments for students who do sell a certain number of times.
And you know,
I think that's actually less important.
And I actually have somewhat of a problem with the laws that create mandatory
punishments for vaguely defined terms like disrupt,
which could be applied to pretty much anything that a sneeze.
Um,
but
I think more important is when administration is saying,
Hey,
these are the values that really,
that this is the wellspring of intellectual vitality that our institution relies
on.
These are the,
the ideals you should be paying to.
This is what's gonna make your experience really worthwhile.
I think students will listen to that instead of maintaining the policies that
say thou shalt not say mean things about you or your classmates.
Uh,
that gets students in a very different mindset when they come to college.
What are the statements are,
or what are the principles that you add?
You guys want to see in those statements?
The principals are just largely,
this is a place of debate.
This is a place of intellectual exploration.
It is not our job as administrators or as faculty members to silence ideas that
we find controversial or protect you from them.
It is our,
uh,
our job.
It is our,
you know,
mission to expose you even two ideas that you might disagree with and give you
the tools that you need to analyze them,
think critically about them,
formulate your own ideas and participate in the conversation because that's what
you're going to have to do when you leave after four or however many years
you're here.
That's part of life in our democracy is participation.
If you don't participate,
then you know,
as the saying goes,
if you don't participate,
you have no grounds to complain.
Uh,
we have to,
you know,
really get students in the mindset that these are important life skills and
they're important.
Even in other instances in the workplace.
That can be important if you have a policy position,
if you're working at a company that you think is either bad or is one that you
want to promote,
you have to be able to think about the people who disagree with you.
And what they're going to say,
anticipate their response and formulate an argument that resolves it.
You know,
there's countless situations in the world outside of college where being able to
think critically is incredibly important and,
and really,
uh,
I think that you've got a lot of value out of doing that outside of the
classroom because it teaches you how to contextualize the skill that teaches you
how to apply it,
not just in the,
I read this assignment,
let's talk about it kind of way.
Cause that's really not how life works once you graduate.
I wish it was,
it would make things a whole lot simpler,
but you'd be out of a job probably.
That's true.
I would have to find something else to do.